[Music]
the world has a way of changing
but there's one thing that always stays
the same
you miss the old life deal
every day
crank it all the way up
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
great
superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
i have no intention to leave my work
unfinished
the wall's upside down right now
where do we start
i have a plan oh yeah what is it
is you ready here we go again huh
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
see that wasn't so hard are you ready
is you ready ready okay what are you
doing ready
are you having a staring contest are you
ready
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you
[Music]
are we there yet this beach it's
beautiful
my swimsuit is hurting they do look
small come on let's play hide and seek
have you seen my children mom i'm right
here
he was six years old this morning oh no
mom i'm scared there's something wrong
with this beach we were chosen for a
reason
what's happening
oh only in theaters this summer
hey
just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land how much child support
is she getting from the king pays no
child support no child support for 30
years and you came back
use a dummy
here we go hello i am hakeem jaffer king
of the moon
you are the heir to the throne yes
my son he's supposed to be like the
prince of wakanda wakanda is a fictional
place not
everybody so munda has a very real
nation i don't need no handouts
wait a minute all right
[Applause]
presenting king akim's son from america
and my mom's and his moms
children this is your brother hey kwai
i'm sorry i slept with your man this
happened before we even met it's not
like you're the first man i've ever been
with
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now he's coming to
me i always thought that mika was going
to be
queen a woman isn't allowed to lose
amunda it's the law
did it ever occur to you that megan
wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
[Applause]
i'm getting it from everywhere i am
upset in my family
you must be strong and general izzy
would love nothing more than to take
over zamunda raise it higher
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but it's impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no don't do that that's my mother oh
don't you say that no not to his mother
i'm almost ready to become a prince
almost it is time
ceremonial circumcision prince power
royals
ain't gonna sharpen you too nephew
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
hey i have an idea how about i make that
lasagna that you love tonight
you know from scratch like i used to
live
i used to work for some very dangerous
people
they came after my family they stole my
kitty cat bracelet and you don't do that
give me that kitty cat bracelet
it's been a hell of a day it's done
nobody
in theater is only april 2nd rated r
[Music]
you